Hello, hello, everyone!
Pre-recorded Doki here, and we are back with another
sponsored video!
Bum-Bum-Bum!
Today, I am sponsored by Blue Protocol Star Resonance to
check out their newest MMORPG experience in an
anime-inspired world with its immersive PvE combat with
casual gameplay, creating dynamic and accessible adventures
for all types of players.
And, best of all, it's currently available now!
Yes, right now on PC and mobile.
So, I guess you know the drill, Dragoons.
Make sure to click the link in the description below and try
to game out.
All right, other pre-recorded Toki, it's time to take it
away.
No chat is here to help you.
For one guy, you throw at least.
Wow, thank you pre-recorded Toki.
That was a great intro.
Have you ever thought about becoming and transitioning to
live Toki?
Let's dive into it.
So, apparently, you can create your own character, team up
for raids, or have fun with friends exploring and crafting i
don't know if i'm gonna make any friends today but we'll see
all right body type oh oh my gosh do i want to be me or okay
i'm sorry okay don't be me me after you fixed me oh i think
like this would be the closest actually wait what's this oh
is it
Yeah, you know, you know who you are.
I mean, I really like the default eyes.
You're already so cute.
I mean, I'm already so cute.
Oh, I have stars.
Oh, wait, that's so cute.
That's so retro, Doki.
Oh, wait, I'm buffed this.
Oh.
Very accurate.
Very accurate, Doki.
Right there.
Best performer.
Because I was in long range using guitar as a weapon.
He knows.
Wait, is this a bar?
I would like to be the guitar man, please.
If they don't like my music, then they gotta speak to my
guitar.
All right, hello.
Yes, I'm floating.
I can't see clearly.
Oh, let's go into the danger.
That's always a good idea.
I'm so smart.
It's like a horror movie where instead you turn around, you
go straight in.
Straight into the danger.
Nothing bad can happen.
Oh, yeah, I got used to guide.
It's what I've always wanted.
All right, oh, okay.
okay guys i gotta do the settings thing my sense is so high
right now do i have new mail uh you have unlocked yay free
stuff i always love free stuff guys oh my god get a dog oh
my god i got a dog oh my god it's dad he sent me dad well
there's some brand new clothes for you by the window make
sure you wear them properly okay where's the one oh there oh
that's okay i thought like in a window as in facing this
okay i have to open the door
wait are they spilling money out of me what she didn't save
me for free oh you picked it for me wait she undressed me
wait wait a minute all right not dokey that is not a joke
guys it's not a joke i'm gonna be not dokey and i'll start
Doki Bird Guild.
Yay!
I mean, someone's gonna take Doki Bird as soon as the
sponsor videos out.
Yeah, but you won't be the leader of the Doki Bird Guild.
Oh, this is a big-ass city.
Okay.
Oh, are these real people?
Hey, guys.
Activate the hub.
Oh, I can view the map.
Oh, my God.
How big is this map?
There's so much more.
I assume like...
Oh, that is a lot.
to explore because there's like here uh i want to dance with
you how how to dance oh i'm poor poor poor people can't
dance again wait oh there's my mount oh my god wait i can
ride a box like what a dog oh i'm gonna i picked the box i'm
sorry i picked it i have to pick the box and continue to be
active at the sea breeze festival before we actually tried
every single activity available oh we're champions across
the board so we got like prize money don't pretend you can't
hear me who said that who who's this girl or guy oh it's a
guy we secure the championship in just one day that's me oh
my gosh i'm gonna be famous soon oh he's got a second that's
right don't talk to me.
You're only second place.
Uh, speak like you weren't raised.
Okay.
Speak like you weren't raised by AI.
Wait, that's so good.
I gotta use that for future insult.
Oh, there's a bounty.
Wait, bounty means money.
Let's grab that.
I won't progress enough so that I can make a guild.
Just gotta go outside.
Time to go to danger.
It's fine.
I have my guitar with me.
Check it out.
There's Luna on the ground.
Where is it?
Are raising and pricing Even Capricorns are raising in the
spam.
Oh, okay.
A fortune we might collect.
All right, time to kill some animals, I guess.
Oh, oh, the level three.
That's right.
Get over here.
That's like, what you're meat?
All right.
What did I get out of it?
Oh, my God.
Okay, just spawn here.
Wait, that's so convenient.
That's right.
I'll use everything.
How much?
Okay, I need three.
All right.
It's not overkill, guys.
I'm gonna ult.
Giving some sick-ass beats.
Her skill is exceptional.
Far beyond most rookies.
The way you pursue that tale, there's something oddly
familiar.
What can I say?
I'm talented.
I'm so humble.
So humble.
Oh, these are the goblins.
There's the snow knight.
Oh, there she is.
He?
She?
Oh, that's cute.
That's a cute outfit.
Very intimidating.
That's a snow knight sang there.
Yeah, that's definitely...
It's a midsummer miracle.
Okay, we can all...
We should see that he's not a real snowman.
Can we not?
Alright, we both have, like, zero IQ running in this noggin.
Oh, wait, she...
They know each other.
Um, that's not Lady Rona.
That's a cosplay.
That's just a Lady Rona impersonator.
So now the goblins?
Yeah, they...
Oh, wait, what?
They're back up?
Oh.
These guys?
Come on, get up.
Oh, perfect dodge.
make damage okay we're not i don't know guys dodging is very
hard um guys i don't know you guys know that i'm not really
really good at dodging oh it consumes and dissolves any
living being touches oh that's not good oh whoa wait a
minute wait the void is bad yeah i still would like my i
like how choice is like no i can't let you be in danger and
then the other choice is like I want my money.
You know which one I picked.
What key is this?
Yeah, what do these keys open?
Oh, there's open chest.
Okay, there's the chest.
Oh, oh god, that's a big ass chest.
All right, what did I get?
Oh, I got a new weapon.
Oh, it's level 20.
I would like to replace it.
I got a better guitar now.
Yay, yeah, who would find me?
My, that's right.
You're getting old, lady.
Get out of there.
times old man oh here we oh my gosh i'm so oh i have wings
oh my god i'm so fast my god that's so fast hey bob there's
bob oh that's awkward i hope bob didn't see that hey bob oh
you're level five interact hey bob
There's a void on what we do, don't touch it.
Who else could have been here?
I don't know.
Bob was outside.
Do you think Bob will ever reply back?
Oh, that's a bad guy.
What was he doing?
Get out of here!
Oh, he's been...
Oh, man in black.
Oh, so he's been the one creating the voids.
Where's it?
Man in black.
Oh, oh my god.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where did he go?
Okay, why is Tina not helping?
Okay, there you go, Tina.
I was gonna say, where is Tina?
We don't need dodge.
Where I come from.
There we go.
How much money did I even make?
Oh, there's my... There it is!
There's the box!
Oh my god, it's Miku.
Let's go!
Okay, let's go over there.
Oh, yeah, give me my reward.
Open.
What did I get?
Oh, I got more money.
Oh, more materials.
Click the button to play.
Oh, I can make bubbles.
Wee.
Yay.
Bubbles.
So we should prepare properly.
We're standing in the perfect place for preparation.
Yeah, I like to craft it.
Please.
What?
Um...
Oh my god, it's my bubble.
There's no way to exit the bubble.
I can't get out, guys.
I'm stuck in the bubble.
We're just gonna blow bubbles until it's over.
But bubble.
Bubble.
Oh my god, I have my inventory again.
Oh my.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Let's find Tina's T-Maps.
some clues oh yeah okay okay after this then maybe i can
make my guild i gotta make my guild before anything else the
guild is the most important part oh wait she knows the
handwriting yeah who is it notorious local gang leader oh my
gosh well why don't you just put him in prison forever yeah
get lead us to him gotta teach him a lesson you don't forget
bro that's him bro i can beat him up easily they're just
regular people bro they don't even have weapons like what
like okay like this Like, like, bro, I literally fought a
goddamn monster.
Like, this is sad, bro.
Oh, there, guild, guild, guild!
There's a guild!
Doki Bird Guild.
I love Doki Bird.
You love Doki Bird.
We are Doki Bird.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
efficient.
What?
No, how do I attain it?
Orbs store?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Join my guild.
Guys.
Guys, join my guild and then we'll unlock all these cool
things.
Look at that.
We'll have a grocery store.
We'll have a leisure area, a guild center, a fountain.
Come on, guys.
You know you want a fountain click my link and join my guild
everyone click it oh yes by the way guys by the way we have
the voyages momento so it's a 50-day login reward which will
give all players daily login rewards for 15 consecutive days
you know what that means free stuff we all love free stuff
free stuff is always nice oh yeah so there's some new
outfits there's one called a zino mimic, which can be
obtained by the meow system.
Oh, there it is.
Where's this?
Oh, wait, that's sick.
Oh, my God.
I'm like a little royal knight.
Whoa.
Why look badass as hell?
The helmet stays on.
Oh, that's so like... Oh, my... Okay, that's actually sick.
I really like that.
Oh, my God.
I got a bow in the back.
Oh, that's cute.
What else is there?
I know there's two more outfits.
Oh, there it is.
The card.
drive.
Oh my god.
Wait, let's see what this looks like.
Oh yeah, your mount is like a motorcycle.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I get a motorcycle too.
With no helmet.
There's also a third limited outfit and I think you got,
it's from the battle pass here.
So, I think you have to get to level 30 on the void pass 2
and it's called Envoy of Night.
And you can get it after purchasing the void pass 2 and
getting it to level 30.
So you get to look like either this dapper young man or this
hot late young lady and i think they have there was one more
thing i need to show you guys there's another special
feature here called dragon shackle event and it's like a 10
to 20 player rate where after winning you can earn like
exclusive rewards so i'll show you guys a video of it it's
pretty sick like there's like 20 of them you guys have to
beat up a dragon you can see that see they're not trying to
beat up this dragon i don't think that's 20 people i think
that's like 10 but you know close enough but you know
there's a lot of fun things you can do a bunch of people if
you want to do the Dragon Shackle event, you should join my
guild.
And that's how you'll find 10 people, you know?
That's the easy way.
Guys, remember to click the link in the description and join
my Doki Bird Guild.
Made by not Doki.
Anyway, I had a great time checking out Blue Protocol, Star
Residence.
Thank you again for the sponsor.
I hope everyone enjoyed watching pre-recorded Doki checking
it out.
Remember to join my guild.
You have to click on the link in the description so you too
can join my guild.
It really does support the video and support the sponsor.
Thank you again, everybody.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, pause, check, get up and
run around to get that blood flow.
And if you sit up for me watching this video, head to bed
because you deserve it.
Pre-recorded, Toki, signing off.